الضحك هو استجابة عالمية ، فهو
متصل بالنظام
وليس له علاقة بالسعادة والفرح بقدر ما يتعلق
بالولاء والتحالف ،
ربما يرشدنا الضحك إلى كيفية
تطوير الفكاهة التي
يبدأ بها الأطفال أولاً في الضحك عند حوالي
ثلاثة و  من نصف إلى أربعة أشهر من العمر
وهذه هي
الضحكة القوية والممتعة حقًا بشكل لا يصدق
إذا كانت المزحة فعلًا غير لفظي ، نبدأ في
رؤية هذا النوع من الفكاهة في عمر سبعة أو
ثمانية أشهر ، دعني أرى قبعتك
إذا كنت  نتحدث عن النكات اللفظية
بقبعة لطيفة ، ثم بالطبع علينا أن
نتحدث عن الأطفال الذين هم
أكبر سنًا بقليل
والذين يوجد
مخلل مخلل يطرقون المخلل
الذي يخبرنا الرضيع شومر عن
الأطفال الرضع أنهم أكثر
تطوراً بكثير مما نعتقد
أنهم  يقومون بعمل ملاحظات حول
عالمهم طوال الوقت ونتيجة لذلك
لديهم إحساس جيد جدًا
بالسلوك النموذجي وما يعنيه ذلك هو
أنه يمكننا أن نظهر لهم حدثًا عاديًا
وتكرارًا سخيفًا لهذا الحدث
وليس فقط يمكنهم  أخبر
الفرق أنهم سوف يحدقون لفترة أطول في
التكرار السخيف للحدث
الضحك
يعد الضحك مهمًا للثدييات الاجتماعية
لأننا نعيش في مجموعات ولدينا
الكثير الذي يتعين علينا إنجازه معًا
بدلاً من الاستقلالية ، لذا فإن الضحك
هو إشارة اجتماعية قوية حقًا
يقول أنا أثق بك ، أنا معجب بك ، فنحن في
نفس الفريق الذي نستمتع به معًا ، فقد كان
بمثابة هذا الرابط الاجتماعي